>>Narrator: Whether they are
meeting with foreign ambassadors.
>>Did that sort of brutality affect
any of your personal relationships?
>>Narrator: Or creating
international forums in Second Life,
members of Global Kids are
plugged in to the world.
>>Carole: I was meeting young
people and asking them if they would
like to learn about world affairs.
And they said "Oh yes, please.
You know we never get this in school.
We'd like to know about the cultures
of the people in our classrooms
and no one is ever really giving
us the opportunity to do that."
>>You know because
getting some education,
telling us about the world and stuff-
>>Narrator: Created in 1989, Global
Kids conducts a variety of in-school
and after-school programs at several
locations around New York City.
Activities include the arts.
>>Somebody pass me a blue marker.
>>Narrator: Digital media.
>>Computer program: Return
to school after a week
but don't bother coming back if
you don't have the tuition fees.
>>Narrator: And leadership classes
that promote civic
participation and global awareness.
>>Teacher: Can you think of one
global issue like a human rights
or social justice issue and
write it on your Post-It.
>>Narrator: In the Online
Leadership program students learn
to use new media forms like
gaming and virtual environments
to explore a larger world.
>>Barry: We actually have a class
where the youth go into Second Life,
it's a virtual world, and learn
about global sustainability issues,
and then demonstrate what they
know within that same space.
We still have a teacher here in
Brooklyn, but we also have a teacher
in Scotland who being there in
Second Life co-teaches the class.
And in that space for example, youth
aren't just using a virtual world.
They're using a virtual world as
part of the larger Internet ecology.
>>Student: Currently I'm working on
trying to put the scenes together-
>>Narrator: The virtual video class
also takes place in Teen Second Life.
>>Computer program:
Did you get a book?
>>Computer program: Oh only the
Chinese students get those for free.
>>Tabitha: Now the exciting part
about their filmmaking is they're
not using real-life cameras.
They're using everything virtual.
So they're using Second Life which
is a virtual community as a platform.
They're learning to work with each
other on coming up with a storyboard,
everything from the preproduction
all the way to post-production,
all the little steps
in making a film.
>>...was basically the classroom.
>>Tabitha: Okay.
>>The first semester they're working
on improving their digital
media delivery skills,
and then in their second
half then they talk
about what's the global issue
they want to raise awareness on.
>>And then after he notices
so many injustices going
on in China he decides
to leave with his mother
through the Himalayan
Mountains and into India.
>>Barry: One of the exciting things
about using digital media as a form
of youth media is that not
only are the tools fascinating
to work with for young people.
They're very engaged around it and
they can learn important skills,
but it means that their potential
audience is so much bigger.
I mean the game that we
released three years ago,
The Cost of Life has been played
in the past year and one-half
about over one and
one-half million times.
To have youth know that
their work can be heard
by that many people
can make a difference,
and if that many people can just
enjoy what they've done is a
tremendously powerful experience
to move from being a consumer
to being a critical creator.
And when you become a critical
creator you then view yourself
as a leader, one who can make
a difference in the world.
>>We also visited the U.N.
>>Carole: If young people
have the opportunity to learn
about things they care about they
will be more motivated to read books.
They'll be more motivated to take
action on things they care about,
and they will see themselves
as players on the world stage
and they'll understand
that in order to do that,
they'll have to work
harder in school.
So my approach to dropout prevention
was to turn young people on to things
that they really cared about.
And it actually has worked.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org